[Music]
in eavesdropping eyes news 9 yeah I did
like this
submitted by soggy waffles no no like
crispy and soft on the inside you know
I'm not sorry sucker not a wobble a
woman helped save 2 kids after she saw
the man in front of her texting about
sexually abusing them what huh movie
texting two other sexually abused E
homie yeah what kind of [ __ ]
conversation is that he's a bad criminal
to you don't ever discuss illegal
marriage over the phone be quiet what
I'm serious
disgusting I know but like if you're
trying to sell drugs you don't get her
sure use cold language I know what
you're saying but I'm just talking about
this story over so there was this woman
she the Seattle area preschool teacher
she was on a Southwest Airlines flight
from Seattle to San Jose when she
noticed a passenger in front of her who
has a pretty big cell phone and had
large font on his cell phone that was
happening like this said idiot
I'd like a tablet I give with senior
citizen letters like that big I am
raping children no she's saying that um
she noticed that he was describing to
someone how to molesky's two kids and
what in the [ __ ] [ __ ] step-by-step
instructions and where the kids next to
him you know so I don't have details of
what exactly he was saying I just know
that he was describing or like he was
sending disturbing messages about
sexually molesting young children so she
was it was easy for it or just read it
because it was like right so baby she
was trying to ignore it cubed so cute
way so there's Wi-Fi on South by house
my sons have Wi-Fi I'm not doing so I'm
not sure if they were in the air or
before Oh exactly how it went down but I
just know he was sitting in front of her
and so she was able to glance over at
his phone
like what he was texting turns out that
the 656 year old man named Michael hit
he was texting a 50 year old woman named
Gail one who was carrying out his sexual
requests on this 5-2 children five and
seven year old well as he was texting it
she was doing it apparently that sucks
yeah why didn't she just lie [ __ ]
sick [ __ ] oh yes I'm doing it right now
but the kids are like not with her
because of ladies probably no she was
babysitting these two kids oh my god I
don't know the relation between her and
the kids
I don't know her the relations between
the babysitter and this man and just
know that that happened did she get like
a wire and put it over the front seat
and pull it back around and he's dead
now right she killed him oh wow she
should have been like hey guys I'm a
preschool teacher and I have a lot I'm
on your side by the way bring them all
will have a huge origin and then had the
cops there and then kill them oh no no
no you bring them in lock him in the
room and you turn on the flames mmm
pedophile bakery have you ever seen that
movie hard candy yes like that she like
tortured now that guy he was like a
pedophile online and she showed up and
she was like what 13 to 15 years old
she's the one that played judo yeah like
she tortured him a lot more to him oh my
God if I have a daughter I want to train
her to do that that would be so cool
it's like Hit Girl yes that we got a man
in the boy first because then I'm the
trainer's boy to [ __ ] take care of
her
exactly yeah so the gaiden is that they
haven't specified his relationship to
the kids either know how I feel like you
must be a relative somehow otherwise
like how I don't understand what these
two kids are doing what they've just
been working together for this long
yeah she's a babysitter she's like a
babysitter slash this is her under 20
like so how do I do this
let me explain like it just seems so
demented I don't know maybe when I do
think of like molestation with children
I tried to think about the fact that
they're just messed up in the head
they're not really seeking it out but
this just shows how plotted it is like
yeah so this is she's a puppet master
dude I was thinking they might have met
on some sort of like tennis elbow
pedicle finder [ __ ] pedophile oh he
has the eyebrows of a pedophile looks
like any guy that you would just see
around and that's the scary part it also
has the little favorite there's a pillow
both pokiedotie thing or whatever they
are no they both look like a pedophile
say it's creepy you know they look like
they do miss for fun but they always
catch them when they look crazy it's
related or something the eyes not you
know what it is it's the forehead it's
huge
Chumash is so hurt is okay
hers is huge and it's their eyes too
they look like I like those [ __ ]
children yeah that's what it is off-duty
Santa Claus he look like a highly rebel
officer really bro he needs to have puka
shells in like tribal tattoos he's too
old to have that day it's crazy to me
how she was able to see it too because
like airplanes think you generally can't
see the PERT like unless you're standing
I can't ever see through the slits of
the seat she might have been behind him
on the aisle side and kind of like oh
that's true meaning to and she's like
ooh [ __ ] children with the yeah yeah
that's true because I don't know if you
guys get this but some people just give
me some sort of vibe yeah that just
count like something that they as an
object or something that's happening I'm
just like I hear this voice in my head
that says just watch him yeah pay
attention to what their don't have that
like English in yeah like a great just
got to like this yeah but it's pretty
it's pretty awesome though that she was
able to catch him because as soon as she
started reading these text messages
that's when she pulled out her phone
story taking photos so she had all good
I was going to say how she was able to
so she this is most likely at the
beginning of the plane ride or like
halfway through this you just have to
sit there oh we know yeah they're old
and I was telling a flight attendant and
then the flight attendant contacted
police oh oh oh airport terminal that's
he was arrested they were just waiting
for now they were waiting for him that
means he must have done it for a long
time to where he felt like he could just
do hexed about feel comfortable yeah
like you didn't need to like hide it
anymore
that another screen protector or
anything like that why do we have laws
where we protect people like this I know
I just need to peel his skin
you're Austin yeah and then for the lady
I would say like just put his dead skin
on her and she has to eat it yeah like a
food that's all she gets to eat that and
should I do
shouldn't they just like find us
stainless steel slide I got a children's
slide and heat it from the bottom up and
then have them slide down that thing
naked like over and over because if they
liked it so much they should play with
kid stuff yeah but it's portrait stuff
yeah but then now the whole slide is
like burning red and it's like no middle
like it'll like heat will make plastic
melt sick - yeah you put them on there
and they're [ __ ] melting with the
plastic and dying oh my god they should
be on a swing set
where like it's like fullest ice and
[ __ ] yeah and all the toys have been
completely ruined
I know imagine fighting other like
you're the parent and like your kids
went through the [ __ ] with someone who
you thought you trusted yeah oh man
they're dead
yeah I would write a letter to the judge
and say like all right dude from like
homie to homie like please understand my
pain I have to do this
I'll buy in citizenship what do you do
first off so like let's say you know who
it is ready like for sure 100% without a
doubt so do you immediately act upon
that action or do you plan your escape
strategy on the body first I'm plotting
body another to make it as for I'm not
going to do a quick kill like I'm going
to make sure that the way that I kill
them is so like it would leave trails
everywhere so I have to go back and fix
it because I would I want to go to jail
right no I don't want to go interesting
like a fight at 100% confirmation the
first thing I'm going to do is figure
out okay how am I going to flee the
country and then when I get to that
country how to erase those footsteps and
get
other country and once I have my
evacuation route did I call her seal and
I [ __ ] kill that [ __ ] if in
that time like there's more people more
victims that have you know been under
all times I shouldn't like span our to
solution it yeah I'm coming to here go
to spear dark are like a border punch
but it's true no this is not London I
hope you guys enjoy this video for more
please subscribe to our Channel and you
can check out the last video right here
[Music]